on October 25th 2023 hurricane otus a
category 5 hurricane made landfall on
Mexico's Pacific
Coast 24 hours earlier Otis had been
categorized as a mere tropical storm
weather forecasters got it wrong and the
Cyclone left at least 48 people dead and
caused billions of dollars worth of
damage we know forecasts aren't perfect
but the models did not handle this
well as the world gets warmer the
climate is becoming more volatile more
than 2 million people were killed due to
extreme weather events in the last 50
years we're going to have more floods
more droughts but as extreme weather
gets worse the deaths caused by it don't
have to rise in lockstep seeing what's
coming and warning people can save lives
the problem is not all countries have
the tools to predict the weather
[Music]
accur accurate weather forecasting in
terms of human life is only going to get
more
[Music]
valuable
for
[Music]
in May
2023 torrential rains in the Democratic
Republic of Congo and Rwanda caused
floods and landslides that Swept Away
thousands of homes in the DRC alone at
least 400 people
[Music]
died
je de's loss reflects the tragedy that
can happen when extreme weather isn't
accurately
predicted like the DRC many countries
can't always forecast the weather
reliably the main issue is funding the
the funding is not available to train
people or build capacity of people to
the right level there's a lot of
infrastructure in the global not but the
institutions in the Global South that
should be responsible or un responsible
for the weather and infrastructure do
not have the ability to retain human
resource and
infrastructure weather observations have
historically been taken from weather
stations and Radars on the ground the
more of them there are the clearer the
picture that can be used to make a
weather forecast the problem is weather
stations and radar are expensive there
are far far far fewer weather stations
throughout the global South in fact
weather stations in many parts of Africa
have actually been declining in recent
years it's just not feasible for every
country to implement the number of
ground weather stations that you would
need to really make sure that your
entire country is is safe and is
actually being uh being
forecasted weather satellites that
divide the Earth's atmosphere into grids
providing average climatic conditions
for each Square offer additional
forecasting ability
but they also have
limitations number one the satellite
data is not enough in terms of
resolution number two the ground data
can give you information which you
cannot get from the satellite
date but while ground data remains
unaffordable to many disruptors are
helping to close the observation Gap
there are a couple of companies with
their own weather stations companies
that will fly drones into areas that
they are interested in they are very
ways that they will try and supplement
the data available to them via sort of
Normal public organizations one approach
being tried by
tomorrow. an American startup is even
more ambitious it's really democratizing
access to weather for those countries
that might not be able to have or
implement the number of ground radar
stations that would be needed the
company is aiming to make weather
observations more affordable by taking
radar readings from Space 3 2 1
ignition and lift
off current weather satellites struggle
to see through clouds but affordable
weather satellites equipped with radar
that can penetrate clouds could prove to
be
transformational as governments and
agencies start to use our data in our
satellites we're going to get so much
better at being able to forecast weather
and Implement early Warning
Systems improving observations is one
thing but turning that data into
forecasts is another here new tech can
help as well private companies are
increasing the accuracy of global
weather forecasts and the arrival of AI
has upped the Ane you've got a series of
models that have been released by
companies like Google deepmind Nvidia
Huawei um which have actually done a
pretty good job of forecasting the
weather as accurately and much much
faster than the massive International
institutions
weather forecasting is a natural fit for
big companies with Computing knowhow but
it's not just big Tech who think they
can disrupt the business of predicting
meteorological conditions AI meteorology
allows us to achieve a new standard of
accuracy and detail and
performance AI is unlikely to completely
replace numerical weather forecasting
the most familiar form of weather
modeling but it is shaking things up
Uganda now has an AI based forecasting
computer capable of predicting the
weather for an entire country the
government has rented it from atmo an
American startup that is part of an AI
gold rush in weather
forecasting results from their system
have yet to be published but Uganda was
attracted in part by the low price tag
it has been affordable and accessible
enough that almost any country or region
that wants one of these forecasts can
get one AI might help countries in the
global South to produce more accurate
weather forecasts at a cost they can
afford but groundbased observations
remain critical AI is not a magic fix
for lack of foring tools or equipment
but AI can complement the conventional
methods but more accurate forecasts are
only useful if that information gets to
the people who need it a big victim of
climate change will be uh farmers in
poor countries one thing that is
probably going to be fairly cheap to do
better on is weather data anything we
can do to help them with extreme weather
where you're going to have more floods
more droughts helping them is probably
the biggest climate adaptation thing
that we need to do small holders with
Farms of under 2 hectares produce around
a third of the world's food supply and
are some of the most at risk of bad
weather in Kenya a collaboration between
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
tomorrow now a weather forecasting
nonprofit and the Kenyan government
provides Farmers with text updates on
the weather they use tomorrow. I's AI to
turn the forecasts into
advice a farmer needs to understand when
it's going to rain understand what the
temperature levels will be and you know
for their various crops that'll
determine when they plant when they
harvest or do they go out and provide
some protection uh to the crops being
able to get public data streams that are
mapped into really good weather
prediction out to them through their
cell phone is a a huge
benefit they're not the only ones
texting small holders
in Uganda where over 70% of the
population depends on rainfed
agriculture a un sponsored scheme to
modernize weather monitoring and alert
systems has been a boon to local farmers
and it's not just agricultural workers
who benefit from better access to
weather
forecasts you have uses in all sectors
fance is just one more accurate weather
forast are definitely crucial for
everyone particularly when the worst
happens
Jean isn't alone three out of every four
people on the planet have a mobile phone
but only around half their countries
have a system to warn them of disasters
the stakes are enormous because when
we're talking about things like early
Warning Systems you are talking about
the ability to move lives and
livelihoods out of Harm's Way in case of
an active ongoing disaster which you
know is incredibly critical and is also
really the thin end of the wedge in
terms of adapting to climate change in a
world where disasters are going to be
increasingly
common the World Bank and others
estimate that improving weather
forecasts and early Warning Systems
could have benefits worth
$162 billion a
year more importantly an estimated
23,000 lives per year could also be
saved WEA impacts quite literally every
single thing that humans do from the way
that crops are grown to how Sports
matches turn turn out to how Wars are
fought to how businesses move across
cities climate change is going to make
the weather more extreme and more
variable in a lot of places which means
that the impact of weather on day-to-day
life is going to become more acute in
many cases that also means an increased
prevalence of disasters which means an
increase risk to human life and
[Music]
wellbeing thanks for watching to read
more of the economist's climate change
coverage click the link and don't forget
to
[Music]
subscribe